hello and welcome back to the 2014 US
Chess Championship and u.s. women's
chess championship here in the beautiful
capital of chess in America st. Louis
we're in the gorgeous Central West End
and bred parts of street from the world
chess Hall of Fame and word round floor
of the championship Mountain the women
have a rest day it's Mother's Day many
of the players in the tournament are
mothers so we're giving them a little
rest although we see one one competitor
a year types of abirami and can't get
enough of Jessie she's already watching
the championship with some of her
friends in that take place I'm Jennifer
shaadi I'm with Grandmaster Yasir Sarah
Juan and will be with you for all day
all day yeah all right around 4:00 we
expected it to be very exciting the
women have been having lots of decisive
games yes the men have had a lot of
trials so I think the men today are
gonna be taking over for the woman
you're making a crazy thing exactly and
let's take a look at the standings we
have here for the US Championship
Alexander Thunder man in the clear lead
with two and a half out of three nobody
would have expected that going into
right behind him
we've got Timur grave and grey Robson
with two out of three our defending
champion got a copy yet to get a
decisive support in this camp
he has three drawers one at points in
the women we have our perennial
champions our reigning five-time champ
crush with two and a half and we've got
four-time champion on a satin ski also
with two and a half but one person who's
really making waves thirteen year old I
swore on with two points and also with
all decisive games see being a foreigner
also with two and Grandmaster Maurice
Ashley has something for us on that
absolutely wild game yesterday for
Queens ending hey with Camilla behind
sky T and it's Rita
he's four on Indy Jen it's been an
absolutely thrilling ride for the
thirteen-year-old from California no one
would have expected this in her rookie
debut in the tournament but she has been
playing absolutely fabulous and
interesting chess in our match-up
yesterday against camilla bug and sky
tay was one for the ages it's not often
we see for queensland on the chess board
I haven't seen it in my practice will
you take a look at this position and
here we have it she played the blue 87
and after e3 with a discovered check she
moved her King up and then the move e -
and here they came one Queen landing on
the board extra and now the other and
there's the fourth Queen it was White's
turn in this position however usually
it's a mate but after this move and this
check it turned out that black was
completely fine until this check
occurred and in this moment Camilla
missed her move Queen to c3 was playable
she missed this opportunity to
completely defend the position instead
she played the move King to d4 and that
allowed Queen takes e4 check and after
this trade Queen takes b4 check and now
suddenly white had split pawns in the
position Camilla resigned here and she
was totally disgusted with herself she
knew something had gone wrong after the
game she was analyzing it on her own
trying to figure out what was my mistake
where is the moment in this position and
even here looking at it knowing she
should have found something still did
not find it I'm not sure she found it
even today nevertheless the youngster is
sitting pretty at two points with a day
very exciting for her on the men's side
you have Alexander Lindemann in the lead
also a surprise leader by himself at two
and a half by being chased by the young
ray Robson they should have a
fascinating matchup today very exciting
day at the championships all up for
grabs were the six men trying to see who
will take over the leaderboard back to
you Jenna yes Wow the Four Queens game I
love that very appropriate is Mother's
Day I would think so but I I really
understood Camila
I mean sometimes when you've had a
devastating loss and you're just still
in shock by what happened the great
turnaround just at the end there and you
know he says there and she tries to
figure it out that's what chess players
do the mark of a champion is instead of
whining or feeling sorry for yourself
you're still immersed in the Ches Ches
Ches is about finding truth in the
position right and she's trying to find
the truth really the critical game in
the round and you know look at that game
yesterday I was really excited by it I
mean he's been playing some some good
chat Wow but his preparation is really
what stunned everybody and you were
first of all welcome back I'm really
really happy to have you here jennifer
is the host and yesterday Linderman's
opening preparation as black against
Alejandro Ramirez was devastating
Ramirez really never recovered out of
that opening in a tip today as we see we
have an English first before but it
looks like he simply transposed after
race mode because it seems that he's
moved as deep on so bring it up
interesting so why do you think he
played c4 if his intention was just to
play d4 against Knight f6 because of
course c4 gives black a lot of extra
options like 5 or c5 and so yes you
don't normally see this is c4 is a
subtle move to try to transpose into
position you want you know ray is going
to play a groom felled perhaps and so
see for the only thing I'm good thing is
imagine that Ray wanted to play a Slav
then you play c4 with the idea that in
case of a Slav with c6 let me just show
what I'm talking about that then the
Ivoire right exactly you could you could
transpose it so testing and the cairo is
it well depend up by Vinick is still one
of the sharp line so alright you can
transpose directly into the pan off
after C 60 45 right I just let me show
what in K say that Ray Robson has two
defenses the groom Feld which you want
to play against and the Slav what you
don't so in case of c7 c6 trying to get
into a Slav perhaps
Alex our tournament leader was thinking
that he could transpose directly into a
pan off Botvinnik
which is sharp and so that's the only
reason that you would play the English
move order what okay so I have a
question because I don't usually play
these c4 emotions your area c4 Knight
Essex a d4 right that's what actually
happened so what happens if black plays
a c6 now c6 now okay so you could still
yes you've committed you got black to
commit the knight to f6 so you can avoid
a Noteboom variation and some other
variations where the knight is not
necessarily committed but then you're
right if you still wanted to get into a
Slav you could get it but you've
committed Knight f6 that's super subtle
right so very so so it seems like that
to me it's a little it's just a little
odd because it seems that what you're
giving up the chance for your part of
the play you five is greater than the
real kind of like minuscule things you
might be getting but perhaps not even
actually wanted the place you 45 maybe
that's part of it so that that's a good
point
and Ray did go
for his primary defense qi6 ready to
fianchetto as bishop play groom felled
g3 by white you're a gloom fell player
you're not very happy when your
opponent's playing g3 you want to play
the mainline groom fells which really
occur from the move or Knights 3 and d5
and other felt like being kettle wasn't
like that unpleasant to play against as
long you know there's like some nice
options for active play for black here -
mm-hmm so I think that this will be an
interesting game and we got a number the
group I was always always exciting right
we've got a number of exciting openings
this round actually things that we might
not have except back expected got a
Kamsky in is playing against Ehrenberg
and he played the Trump have ski ya know
he's been known to play London systems
things that are kind of off yet in
theory but usually you see that [ __ ] up
coming to f4 and i35 for sure the Trump
a ski d4 d5 and what white does is he
brings us Bishop out very early this
move Bishop g5 is basically what white
is saying is when you bring your knight
to f6 I have the opportunity White has
the opportunity rather of capturing and
double in the pawns mind you I don't
think that Trump offski really has
enough poison in it too upset Sergei
he's voting age six Bishop back how
would you compare that to the London
because that's also considered to be
like not the most testing opening do you
still think that that gives a greater
chance of advantage than this the funny
part is I do think that the London
system with Bishop f4 is a little bit
more dangerous than the Trump house key
for some reason controlling that a five
square and the diagonal on h2 to be
eight I've seen a lot of players get
into difficulties playing natural moves
as black
like the London okay let's show how that
it had it goes so in the game
gotta has developed his Bishop from c1
to g5 as we'll see in the game later the
London system basically the idea is to
put the Bishop not on the g5 diagonal
attacking the Queen but a little bit
more subtly on the f4 square going down
the diagonal h2 to b8 the reason why the
bishop in my opinion actually has more
is more effective on the f4 square is
there a number of times that this knight
can jump out to be five there are let's
just play a few moves so after say
Knight f3 9mm Knight f6 Knight f3 let's
just imagine a move for example like
Bishop f5 okay so after Bishop f5 c 4 c
e6 a move like Queen b3 you attack this
pawn on b7 and this Bishop on f4 means
that if the Queen ever does land on this
pawn of b7 the pawn on c7 will also be
under threat so I think it's a little
bit more poisonous and by the way that
is a variation the London system which
gotta actually excels at he's got a
tremendous record with the London in the
game the bishop is on g5 we've just seen
this move by Sergey c76 if there's one
negative if you will about the tram
Tomsky is when the bishop obviously when
the bishop is on c1 the pawn on b2 is
defended this move c7 c6 is setting up
for a quick queen development Queen
could come down here to b3 to try to
harass this pawn on b2 and that was what
Serge's move
c7c six is all about it's already got
got ik thinking how is he going to deal
with that potential threat
shall we go around the horn and see
what's that hang in the other game
opening news in the gray of game all
right
Timur got ef-1 yesterday yesterday that
against Daniel nor NORAD it's key to
bring himself up into second place and I
believe we have the Janish gambit okay
8:45 night a three night c6 Bishop b5 we
have the Rui Lopez one of the oldest
gambits in the world and we have this
move f7 f5 very sharp defense by black
black is offering to gambit the pawn on
f5 one of the things about the Janish
gambit is the very sharp variations
require a great deal of study and if you
as white are surprised by this by this
gambit idea of f5 you're almost likely
just to avoid those sharp lines that
occur from captures or from d4 to play
the move d2 d3 the strange thing about
d2 d3 by the way is after captures
captures Knight f6 as we've seen Timur
black in this case is getting a pretty
easy defense opening and one of the
great experts today is Grandmaster Timur
raja raja baath from azerbaijan who has
used this defenses black to good effect
so anybody out there who wants to learn
about this gambit just study the games
of timur raja baath and you'll be in
great shape and let me just see if white
has moved if we have an update indeed
the last move was castles always a good
idea your priority in the opening is to
control the center
get effective squares for your pieces
and a safe king so with the move castles
white tuxes King behind this nice shield
of pawns and timur plays the move Bishop
c5 developing his bishop and preparing
to castle with his king by playing
something like Queen b3 or Queen e2 here
right so that castles will be met by
clean c4 check right exactly gen Queen
d3 is a standard move in this position
so the idea is don't play castles
because with this move Queen c4 you get
a double attack check two blacks King
and you pick up this Bishop on c5 so
black usually has to play the move d76
in order to protect his Bishop before
castling and Mac to play we think he'll
probably play the move Queen d3 and let
me just continue our look around the
horn see next king I'll bring up on our
scoops hi sorry we just looked at that
game that was between typed in the wrong
number
what do we have here Alex honor shook
again one of the pre-tournament
favourites like other players in the
tournament he's getting off to a slow
start
he's made three consecutive draws he's
playing against Sam Shanklin Sam black
like this appears to be a sloth defense
let's see how let's see it from the
start
we have d4 by on a shook as expected and
we do have a Slav the both grandmasters
will be very very familiar with this a
defense as it's one of the most popular
one of the oldest is defenses in chess
a2 a4 just a quick explanation about
this move with black has just captured a
pawn on c4 and he's looking to keep it
he wants to play the move b7 b 5
protecting that pawn on a4 and white has
played the move a to a4 just to prevent
black from playing b5 all of this is
well known opening play III Bishop takes
all of these moves these are the most
popular opening moves by both sides
efore Bishop g6 Bishop d3 the reason
behind this little retreat is now in
this particular position this pawn on e4
is vulnerable to a bishop capture C 3
followed by capturing the pawn on e4 so
white re fortifies the center with the
move Bishop d3 now this very annoying
move Bishop h5 putting the knight in a
pin to the queen on e 2 black is
preparing the counter shot in the center
with the movie 6 e 5 that's why we see
white playing the movie 5 himself to
clamp down in the center Knight goes to
d5 trades trades and again I mentioned
that this bishop this knight in a pin to
that Bishop on h5 is rather awkward for
white so Alex steps out of the pin with
the move Queen III and he wants to play
the move Knight g5 as has been seen in
World Championship match play so the
players are still comfortably in the air
theory the move Bishop e7 the bishop
drops back to Petra square root 5 I'm
just welcome everybody I think there
have been some technical problems for
some people watching um just remind
everyone this is round 4 of the US
Championship our begin is between Robson
and Lenderman
leading me that and the women are off
today yeah they have a free day yeah
happy Mother's Day - yeah absolutely and
happy Mother's Day mom as well and yeah
my my biggest fan my wife Yvette she she
had sent me an email that she sometimes
got booted off the server but she's been
following the action so she likes you so
it must be good you're my biggest fan
right there case that's alright
so Bishop e7
to cover the square g5 it's a very solid
position the only open file in the
position is the C file this is off loops
my arrows terrible this is often where
players will bring their rooks as
quickly as possible to the C file to
control the open file that's very
balanced position going on there well
let's go back to our Thunderman robson
game for those of us who are just tuning
in
alright so we have our tournament leader
Alex Slenderman playing white against
Rey it looks to who looks to have heated
up and gone into more normal channels of
a kind of a groom felled White has
fianchetto to his bishop and Ray just
played the move d5 CD 95 e for classical
control of the center by white with
pawns on e4 and d4 it's called classical
pawn duo for a reason by the way Knight
was booted back 96 all of these are very
standard moves and c7 c5 so what Rey is
trying to do is that Bishop on g7 he
wants to open the diagonal before White
has castled so that in case of a capture
then white loses the opportunity to
Castle and black will pick well-well
regain his pawn by either capturing the
pot on b2 or c5 so Alex did not capture
that pawn and allow the trade of Queens
he played d5 gaining space in the center
castles castles everybody's happy eise
evan ecigs trying to break up the team
of the pawns on e4 and e5 again all very
standard opening play now this move 92
to c3 that deserves explanation because
you would think that white would play
the move Knight on b1 to c3 this
is already developed the problem is is
that after trades this night's future is
actually not that great the square f4 is
not that compelling
so what Lenderman has done with this
moved night eetu to c3 he's little he's
going to give this night on b1 a
different circuit usually that circuit
will be a 3 and C 4 let's see how it
goes
96 93 there we go take stakes and we
have this position so essentially the
question is does this pass pawn on the
d5 square give white an advantage white
white won't want to play moves like
Bishop f4 followed by Knight b5 and to
try to invade on the d6 square so still
very very sharp game we're still unclear
I love the space I like the past pawns
but I do recognize that black has his
own sets of trumps as well it's not just
play on one goal now these two have
battle before actually 2012 the US Chess
Championship it was also over Infeld and
Leonard been one that one is Wyatt and
that line he played the Russian
variation and it was a Russia that so
many really three Queen b3 okay thank
you and that was a really interesting
game and I imagine we have another
slugfest in store for us between these
two young chaps for those of you who are
just tuning in we have Grandmaster
Maurice Ashley and he has something for
us indeed happy Mother's Day everyone
happy Mother's Day to my mom down in
Florida so we have a position in the
game you guys just showed with Lindemann
playing against Robson where the nights
are funky I mean yeah so you just
glossed over those nights going on the
rim as if it's standard fare we teach
our students to put their nights in the
middle of the board
and yet grandmasters are casually
putting their nights wherever they like
particularly on the side of course
there's always specific reasons for that
and the nights one of my favorite pieces
so paradoxical this piece and I
to show you the game between narrowed
its key and Ramirez how its proceeding
and that has some counterintuitive moves
as well
a French defense starting here at Irish
variation and this move Knight G f3 and
now after this trade in the middle
excuse me this trade in the middle
Knight takes d4 Knight to f6 and now
this trade Queen coming to the center of
the board attacking the knight on d4 and
now check this out Knight b5 a sweet
little Royal Fork they're being
threatened and black played the move
Knight a6 ala Robson in the other
position guarding this c7 square that
move was now followed immediately by
Knight to c3 chasing the Queen out of
the center this Knight remember folks
was this Knight once upon a time it's
danced across the board and it's
replaced its brethren on this natural c3
square we're gonna imagine maybe one day
this nights gonna end up on f3 and
they're gonna say well nothing change it
was all standard but look in the next
move as well the Queen under attack and
now the move Queen to d8 and it's only
the Knights starring in the show yet
again the dance of the Knights we're
gonna see them prancing all day today no
doubt as these young players go into
original territory here at the US Chess
Championships back to you guys
prancing Knights I like that I like that
one of my favorite pieces as well one of
them I like both yeah and given my
choice over a large number of positions
the majority at the time the bishops
will be the better piece but you know
what I think the Knights really make
chess magical that's fact you know
because they you know you a knight can
do the Royal Fork of winning a king and
a queen and they can just move that they
can jump over pieces and no other no
other piece has the qualities of the
night
yeah it's nice that the night has the
rules of the night have stayed the same
so you can look at ancient test problems
with the book in the night and they
follow our same rules right
whereas the bishop and the Queen by
contrast have changed a lot right in
fact the Queen used to be the weakest
piece of the moor right right so that
must have been a really different game
very difficult to execute checkmates
when the French introduced the new
powers of the Queen in the 15th century
it was called the mad Queen so some
little historical tidbits I think
mother's day now the Queen is
appropriately the most powerful piece in
the Lord Micah to be appropriate me okay
how old is it let that slide okay very
good on Mother's Day
you gotta be you gotta give me yeah and
we do have a an interview with Rex
Sinquefield from yesterday so yeah right
now caught that he is of course the
founder here of the st. Louis chess club
and it was a brilliant interview the
hilarity of course was that when he was
interviewed that was the the moment we
had a transmission problem so the joke
was that that Rex broke the system but
it was a great interview and it will be
coming up thanks you guys it's my
pleasure to welcome Rex to the show
Thank You Rex this tournament is
something special I mean we come to the
st. Louis every year and we really
enjoyed has it lived up to your
expectations so far this year except for
one game in the first round this one is
really good there's as as Grandmaster
Maurice Ashley likes to say there's a
lot of blood on the floor
indeed this Ryan has been quite exciting
and we won't talk too much about that
first round game between number one and
two in the tournament Oh what what
should we expect to see in st. Louis in
the near future what's your biggest give
me your biggest vision for chess here
and say hello my biggest vision is
having a world championship match here
Wow and the greatest vision of all of
course were to see you play in it
that would be quite a vision and I'm
working to become a stand-up comic yeah
indeed
we don't expect that to happen anytime
soon that the tour we know some some
interesting initiatives that you're
trying here or I believe you had some
some news on the political front you
know you and I don't necessarily share
the same political views but some
interesting things have been happening
in a st. Louis area I know we don't
share political views and I'm always
happy to enlighten you anytime you want
to be enlightened yes we did have some
great news in the state of Missouri it's
been heralded nationwide and that is
Missouri finally passed its first tax
cut in 100 years the governor vetoed
that the General Assembly overrode it
which is a heroic feat for any general
any body any legislative body to
override a veto in this country given a
two-thirds requirement is a remarkable
achievement
indeed you are what are your plans for
the Sinquefield cup and we they say it's
gonna happen know who you planning it's
gonna happen and you know the bar was
set by the Zurich Tournament recently
when it was the strongest tournament
ever held
so I said to joy Bray our overseer of
the club here and Jennifer Shahadah my
long-suffering teacher you got to be
long-suffering if you're going to teach
me you know and virtuous I said we've
got to try to beat Zurich I want this to
be the strongest tournament ever held
any place any time and we're gonna try
it's not going to be easy of course we
got to get probably top the top six out
of the top ten yeah that would be
incredible so have you said on
invitations to gotta have Carlson you
got a Varon e'en Kramnik I'm non Topalov
those guys sent them out I don't know
exactly who has accepted and I'm
probably out of my element here I do
believe Carlson has already accepted I
don't know about the others okay we
won't trust your word cuz you're don't
worry I'm very unreliable you are also
running on Garry Kasparov's ticket in
the elections barber is running for
president of feed a what possesses you
to want to become part of a chess
political team I lost my mind
no he called me up and he said would you
consider being on my ticket and I said I
don't know what I would do but okay if
you think could I help he said it would
definitely help us I can't imagine why
but I said yes
and I know you're pretty strong-willed
guy but I haven't met too many tour de
forces like as Barham how much do your
opinions matter in those discussions
well it mattered if I said yes or no but
otherwise I'm not getting involved in
the election you know that's that that's
really his no one else should get
involved they should let him run that so
what are the kind of changes does he
plan to have that's different from
what's there now well you know he wants
a unified rating system and I think he
wants to have multiple headquarters for
fidei and he has said you know back
before World War two everything great
that happened in chess happened in the
United States and that's not true
anymore and I think he'd like to see the
United States return to its preeminent
status I don't know all of his other
ideas but I can tell you this in talking
to him many times he is a phenomenal
visionary and just wonderful for chess
absolutely I mean he's been that way
since he was in his 20s that's right
he's been tremendous and now he's
touring African country it looks like
his frequent flyer miles must be through
the roof the way he's rap goodness yes
fortunately somebody provided him a
private jet so that helps yeah that
indeed Rex
thanks so much I know that you you know
you have some weird opinions like I
won't talk about the card knows how you
torture me with it gardels Yankees but
we always appreciate your being on the
show well I always appreciate talking to
you about the Cardinals in the Yankees
do you know Maurice that the Cardinals
and Yankees have met five times in the
World Series and the Cardinals have won
three of them and the Yankees only two
can you explain that I heard that before
guys help me have you noticed how ugly
Jennifer's become today I do want to say
this serious thing with you guys with
Ben Yasser yourself and Jennifer we have
the greatest commentary team in the
world bar none there's nobody closer i
watch as you do all of these top
tournaments in the world and I listen to
the commentators and I watch them and I
say we are orders of magnitude better
than these people and that's my hat's
off to all of you you guys are off the
charts good or really are we appreciate
those kind words I
have to pay for it later with a Yankee
story or two Rex Sinquefield always a
great interview thanks so much for
joining thank you so much wow that was
one heck of an interview yeah it was
wonderful those of you who've been
asking me it ever since I talked about
the CTO cup and how it's coming back
people wasn't asking me for more details
where there were a couple details
revealed they are that interview right
he mentioned that it's gonna start on
August 27 but in August yeah and you
also said that we are almost certainly
gonna have Magnus Carlsen and that's
what he said in the interview and
hopefully we can match that with reality
right one of the problems we're
currently having of course is that
Magnus is going to be playing a World
Championship match later this year with
Vichy we the players contracts are a
little bit up in the air because this
world championship match dates haven't
yet been announced but we're hopeful of
having the very very best tournament
ever held and of course keep posted on
Twitter on st. Louis chess club's
Twitter Facebook and website because you
will get all the details and hopefully
we can announce more of them while the
championship is taking place the only
part I didn't like about the interview
was when he called me ugly well that was
because you are not any weren't here he
was actually referring to the to Mary
all commentators then that bet Ben took
the hit on that one by the way
and of course grandmasters Ben Feingold
and Robert has are at Lester's every day
here in st. Louis so those really you've
gotta come in person mm-hmm if not this
tornament comes back for the same field
cup because it's amazing you know we've
got this beautiful Chess Club the museum
across the street there are awesome
events there's a sports bar where we
have chess sets everywhere and live
commentary of the game well there's just
hope yeah if indeed and one of the most
shocking or wonderful moments of the
Sinquefield Cup that I witnessed last
year was when the players all the
players in the field were doing a book
signing
I'm not kidding the line wrapped around
the entire Street from Lester's all the
way to hunt at the end of the corner
there
to see all of those chests man standing
in line man with their books
it was brilliant it was great great
stuff was Aronian and Magnus's first
major event in the mecca right they've
come here both for like I know magic
time so many things with g-star and
other promotional events but a serious
competition this was his first one
exactly they both loved it by the way
Levon wanted a better result but he
really enjoyed himself as well shall we
see what is going on in some of the
games today in the fourth round here I
will copy again our first on our first
board the game between Ray Robson a few
moves have been played since we last
left it we got the situation and ray
connected his rooks advanced his queen I
think I my definition of when does the
opening end and transition into a middle
game my definition is whenever the rooks
are connected okay that makes it real
simple
so for blacks point of view once he's
connected his rook s-- his opening is
over white does the same thing playing
Queen b3 his rooks are now currently
connected so by my definitions the
players are now in the middle game rook
e8 one thing my students always try to
do whenever they've got that Bishop in
that Queen lined up they always want to
try to play Bishop h3 so instead of four
key a let's go through the pros and cons
of that idea exactly so rook Bishop h3
by the way is one of those it's a kind
of a statement the statement says that
this bishop on g2 protects your protects
the White King so with this move Bishop
h3 I want to get at your King and
potentially getting an attack against
the King the question is is this Bishop
really that good because the pawn is
still on d5 so let's say I would play a
move like rook d1 let's say you were
trade trade trade and now you've got to
deal with the issue of how are you going
to keep that pawn on d5 block
the one reason why ray may not have
wanted to develop bishops trade Bishop's
pardon me he did play the move rookie
aide but while we were watching Rex's
interview Maurice was at was posing the
question what about Bishop d3 attacking
the rook rook d1 and then playing c5 c4
and trying to anchor that bishop on d3
so this is a kind of a judgement call
should we trade bishops or would you
rather have that bishop on that very
nice central square
d3 fascinating pros and cons here I mean
I think this is that kind of stuff those
of you listening at home you should be
very grateful that you got your h3
you're not you're not gonna get an
answer about the value of trading those
bishops from your computer engine and I
noticed that the lower rate of the
player the more they just really want to
trade pieces right so that's why it's in
here it doesn't look like it's a
terrible idea
no nothing but it's it's interesting
because normally it would be a 5-star
idea the bishop is the only defender of
the King there it's but I liked your
point about how it's actually not that
strong because the white pawn on d5 kind
of block yeah and we've got a
grandmaster Ashley with some more
thoughts on this a critical game here
indeed Jed a very unusual position but
actually it's a typical position for
theory I checked the databases and this
game has been seen quite a lot in the
black side we've seen Belyaev ski
playing against fiddler playing the
black pieces and we know those are two
top players
well this position in my database at
least I was not able to find robsons
next move rook F to e 8 this is a new
variation it looks like anyway a novelty
and we saw that Lenderman spent some
time on this position before playing his
next move which was to bring the rook to
d1 preventing this Bishop from going
into d3 which has been played a couple
of times before so we'll see whether or
not this move this wrinkle with rook to
it work to e8 work F to e8 is an
improvement over the standard lining or
at least what has been seen I mean
that's what chess is about is making
your own moves every once in a while but
we saw Robson playing this
move eyeballing this bishop but not
clear that it's the best move into
position we'll see how the game unfolds
I'd like to point out from this diagram
this interesting issue about these
Knights take a look at the Knights on
this rim you get this knight on a six in
the Akopian free tall game we see this
knight on a six in the narrow disky
Ramirez game and another night on a six
in Lindemann Robson there might be a new
rule the Queens Knight goes to a six
right maybe yes what do you think about
that one
check this out also in the comm Sookie
Aaron Berger game the night going to e7
instead of going on the natural f6
square so very odd Moe's being played in
a lot of games one game I like to point
out actually there are couple of games
you might want to take a look at this
move a3 we saw the weird hop of the
Knights a queen dropping back and now
now our disk is played to move a three
stopping a bishop or a knight from going
to the B Foursquare another one of those
weird moves you say don't play those
moves I tell my student don't play those
moves but grand mass is very specific to
the strategy in each given position and
we'll play unorthodox moves like this
one in order to prevent specific ideas
from happening another board I'd like to
point out that was very strange to me is
this game a decision made by owners
shook in this exact position here with
his queen ahead of his bishop already he
played the move Knight to g5 threatening
on 87 and allowing this trade so that he
could get the two bishops away from his
opponent this looks like a bad trade at
first after the move Bishop to g6
because this trade would leave black
with a great night against the not so
good Bishop bucking up against these
pawns but honest trick at a very
specific point he refused to trade and
now he attacked this night and suddenly
there's some funny business with the
night bishop able to go into e7 and then
some pressure along this diagonal so
really interesting play nuanced play
happening now are the championships
original stuff it seems like there's
some exciting games afoot
back to you gen and yes I remember the
World Championship match between Kramnik
and and non played in Bonn in 2008 that
they got this position of the slot
defense that Maurice was just showing
and an on really squeezing Kramnik with
the two bishops and Vladimir was very
uncomfortable in some of those games so
only shook trying to get his first
decisive game under first win under his
belt seems to have gotten the position
the type of position anyway he wanted so
I'm gonna give him the edge in terms of
opening preparation between those two
experienced grandmasters I've also
brought up my screen the game between a
Cobian and a Josh freed al we haven't
paid too close attention of that game
and again
Murray's talking about the misplaced
Knights on the edge of the board let's
see what how this game and play unfolded
from the start it was also a queen pawn
opening a lot of games and surprisingly
the lower rated player has the positive
score they play just a lot of opens okay
Las Vegas Foxwoods Chicago for I think
decisive results and Kobe only only had
two Wow
I wouldn't have guessed that one at all
so Josh played this move Bishop b4 check
what we call the BOGO Indian White has
three main ideas of blocking the check
either by moving this Knight to c3 to or
te to the main line traditionally has
been Bishop d2
I played the BOGO Indian from both sides
and Bishop d2
usually is the key move in my own games
blocked with a knight castles a2 a3
putting the question to the bishop do
you intend to capture my knight yes or
no the answer was a no Josh draw back
with his bishop and now the most
challenging variation goes e to e for
Akopian
played it a little bit slower this is
small ball so to speak
e 2 e 3 he have
c75 and natural move for black to try to
counter-attack in the center captures on
c5 and now what white is hoping white is
hoping if that black isn't unthinkingly
recaptures the pawn at once then after
the move be two before the bishop drops
back white has this nice edge of on the
Queen side these advanced pawns practice
has shown that white has advantage in
this position so Josh played a very
crafty and move I like a lot a 785 that
pawn up with the night instead exactly
while simultaneously slowing down the
movement b2 b4 now what's very key it's
funny this move b2 b3 looks like oh I'm
doing nothing special I'll just play
Bishop b2 but I was just wondering after
Knight a six can white be super crafty
and say well did you consider the move
b3 b4 because the difference now is you
can't just simply grab the pawn because
oops there's a pin you'll drop a rook so
I'm just wondering if the move b4 could
say hey guess what Josh I'm just trying
to maintain my pawn on the c5 square
okay so the idea here is that if we were
to move up for instance if we were to
move our work like to be eight or
something like that
maybe one yourself all this remains
perhaps a different approach may be
moving the Queen so there are thirty of
ways to avoid losing a blue you know
letting us regain our bombs right I'm
not letting you regain the pawn and the
nice way that you want to regain the
pond I'm forcing you to make some
awkward moves and your attempts to win
though on back oh here maybe I can play
b6 it's a
was better you have another gonna meet
here you I was thinking that okay b5
moving well I'm not saying I hunted
percent I like my game the night might
either be very good on the outpost
before or it might actually be poorly
placed in the meanwhile I do have a
protected past pawn in this Bishop on b2
could still be a star of the game and my
rooks on the open file so I'm just
saying that the move b3 b4 has to be
taken under consideration and it's like
one of the slight moves you just play b3
right so you're not expecting the pawn
to move again having just moved a moment
earlier Wow well you're an expert in
this line you said you play it for both
sides and you mentioned that you were a
little surprised by Knight bTW too
because you think the lines of Bishop d2
offer way to kind of clear advantage not
clear I don't mean to say clear the
likely path to a small advantage that's
right that's right that you you have
main lines and their main lines for good
reasons and Bishop d2 after centuries of
practice and tens of thousands of
grandmasters and games that's the most
popular move and it's the most popular
move for a reason you trying to get a
big edge but I know that var is one of
those players that likes to postpone the
heat of the battle to the later stages
of the middle game he doesn't want an
opening clash where his opponent's is
already super well prepared and can just
box out you know 20 moves yeah he wants
to he wants to postpone the battle for
when there's time trouble considerations
and other things the b5 check Sicilian
when players who don't want to draw they
play ninety seven exactly ninety two is
really a signal that he wants a super
fighting game he can play for an event
adjust Bishop d2 but he wants the game
to be even more tense and exciting so
that's good for us yes we do have some
viewer questions if you want to
participate in the show go to a hashtag
us chess champs
and we do have a membership on offer by
one of our sponsors here just calm so
Diamond memberships yeah keep us keep us
coming with the questions we got some
good remarks already here's one question
that we have I should also point out
that we've got kids day here at the st.
Louis chess club
oh so on Sundays we have normally they
have great kids classes and the kids
came in this morning is Wow and they
submitted some questions for the
broadcast the best ones got Chesky comm
memberships which is a sister site of
chess calm all right and here's one of
them and we've touched on this already
today so that's awesome what is your
favorite piece and why well let me take
first crack at that the worst piece when
I was a beginner the worst piece with
the night it was such a tricky piece it
was jumping everywhere and I couldn't
remember how the night moved and I would
always make illegal moves with my night
and my experience chess friends would
laugh at me because the night was
terrible so I worked really really hard
at trying to master the the moves of the
night and to understand where it could
go I worked so hard on learning how to
move the night that it became my
favorite piece sort of like I came to
really admire and enjoy it and when I
actually was raised on bliss chest I
loved 5-minute chests three minute
chests and even bullet chess and in in
the games of chess where you play really
really fast the night is the trickiest
piece that's the why to the question
it's such a tricky exactly how about you
Jeff
well I think that I love the Queen
because of the history behind it no you
know I'm fascinated by the history of
chess it's been around for so many years
and the rules that we have have been
around for five hundred years and it's
incredible that you don't see a lot of
other activities like that
no we're using exactly the same rules
and we can go back 400 years and look at
chess games played by those rules but
the Queen was the last critical change
there
that's right so that's fascinating to me
and I think a good way to get more girls
and women into the game making between
the most powerful piece that's right I
mean we've IDs well just in general like
when you tell girls that the queen is
the most powerful piece I think they
like that yeah that's true
when you tell a group of girls that do
think that they mostly see their see
boys playing mm-hmm you explain this to
them they really like yeah they'd be
getting excited in Maurice we actually
have one more quick question for Marty
oh sure I wanted to get obvious on that
to us number of moves you've ever won in
the least amount of time Tristan boy
most of my games have gone pretty long I
I wouldn't be surprised if I once won a
game in 12 moves so I'm not checkmating
in two and three and four but most of my
games
it takes me a dozen moves before I
really have one let's let's put it that
way you are you better in that regard
than I am yeah yesterday I beat Waxman
what's your favorite piece and what's
your shortest game my favorite piece is
definitely the night I used to not care
at all somebody would ask me that
question I'd say whatever piece gives
checkmate but now after studying the
night as you have yeas I've really been
enthralled by this piece and I've been
able to create a few studies that now
that you said that I'm going to share
one of my favorites with you this
position here it's white to move and win
and take a look at this nine wide is
already up a piece but white has a very
interesting path to the wind white plays
the move Knight to f2 and now black
plays King to e3 and in this position
white cannot play King to g2 to guard
the night because the King simply goes
back to have four and white is in zoogs
wrong white has to go
to h3 so after King to e3 the only move
for the knight is d 1 followed by King D
2 now King to be to a knight to be -
that's chase by King C 3 now Knight to
a4 again the only way to go King to b4
and now suddenly the move Knight to b6
the knight is untouchable of course
because the pawn will quickly become a
queen so the King now plays the move
King to b5 and now the night goes to the
seize 8 square King takes pawn and now
the night makes a trek back to this G
pawn after all that marching the King
comes up the board the night goes to f7
the King goes here and now we have a
different race of foot after the move a5
and now the night goes to the e6 squared
now this position is really interesting
because now after the move a5 Knight d4
the King goes after the night trying to
capture it and white plays the simple g5
and unfortunately for black after King
takes pawn up pawn up pawn up pawn up we
get a queen and I think if those of you
have seen the searching for Bobby
Fischer movie you know the next trick
the skewer at the end winning the game
so and now you have to travel all around
to finally die in the middle sacrificed
itself to have this position occur now
as far as my shortest game is concerned
I've one game and as little as of course
four moves you know playing as beginners
but in in serious competition and about
14 moves playing I remember in Saint
Martin I played the game I won't mention
the Gaia beat though it's wouldn't be
nice for him
back to you guys nice puzzle with
scorpion sting at the end there that
skewer with the Queen h8 check picking
up the Queen that's a short game I want
it to be in st. Martin well-planned
indeed if you're gonna win a short game
do it in Saint Martin
another shout out I'd like to give to
one of our most talented viewers we've
got a shot Chandra who is 14 years old
and recently earned his first Grand
Master norm at the Marshall chess club
Invitational where he also won
tournament Wow
he wrote an article about that for
u.s. chess and yeah he also writes so
the kiddies are extremely talented
because actually got it right post about
the st. Louis chess club in the u.s.
championship so great to see some of our
most talented youth watching these games
and no in his case knowing that one of
these days he's gonna be in one of these
seats Wow well welcome aboard and many
other hopefuls right and what is the
shoutout what does he say
well he said that um it's glad to see a
friend of mine and also one of the pre
my pre-tournament picks my master
Alexander Lenderman off to such a great
start
oh very nice and then um he also says
that he also has a blog post on there so
you can see that all his uh handle on
Twitter is quest to GM quest GM I like
it one third of the way there now Jen I
yesterday I had to play your role as
host and I didn't give out those diamond
memberships on chess calm but I promised
our viewers that you would be doubly
generous today so you have a task of
finding our best question for those
members that's right I think we have a
couple of chests out called memberships
offer AB so make them good guys by the
way guys I forgot the best part of this
story the really interesting part of
this story about Knights I just showed
you this endgame that this composition
that I created and the reason I created
it was because of one Gary Kasparov and
Gary had we were having a conversation I
had a different study and he solved it
so easily he was like that was boring
and I was like wow okay so I went home
and I created this one it took me a lot
of time to create because there's one
variation that I forgot to point out and
it's this one after the night went to e6
I just showed you the move a four night
to d4 King to c4 g5 the night the King
does not have to take this Knight right
now and go into that line you could also
push right this line is playable and
after g6 push again and pushing doesn't
help now because
the poem becomes a queen right so night
drops back the king goes after the night
the night goes in the corner and now the
king goes to be to push takes and get a
queen all looks fine and dandy in this
position black now plays King here and
we know this position would be a draw
without the H pond however in this
position white can win with a simple
ladder series of checks and I think you
see what's coming as after this check
King here and now we know this technique
and now check the King has to go into
the corner to be stalemated and right at
this moment white plays King to g4 h3
Queen c2 and after h2 27 moves long its
mate 27 moves great endgame it took me
about three hours to figure out this
study I was really proud of it I
presented it over the phone it was
talking to world champion former world
champion Garry Kasparov about other
business and I said oh I improved my
ending and he said in his head he said
so what's the position and I tell him
the beginning position the initial
position which was here before Knight f2
and we were on the phone I said I told
him and now I'm proud of myself he sat
there he said give me a second and he
waited it was literally about 10 seconds
and I'm smiling to myself before he said
oh that's really nice at the end you
play not this line he said Oh at the end
you play King G for this move he said oh
that's really nice at the end you play
King g4 and then you made that's pretty
and this is 10 seconds later and that's
like wow okay that's why they call him
the monster that sees all incredible so
humbled by that ending I'm so proud of
the ending but you know guys like Garry
they make chests look easy back to you
guys boy when somebody steals your
thunder like that he works so hard
you've got this beautiful setup and the
guy just solved the problem half a
minute it's like
very talented world champion of course
why you should be a few day resident as
well yes as Rex was saying he's Rex's on
Gary's ticket and it's going to be a
very interesting election at the de
Chess Olympiad in Norway this year it
will be held in Tromso in August yeah in
fact the sing folk op is following the
Olympiad we're expecting that Magnus is
going to lead the Norwegian team and the
Russian there Armenians we're hopeful
that we'll have a shout to get on the
puck on the podiums as well we'll be led
our team will be led by Hikaru Nakamura
and by the way been corrected me
yesterday by pointing out boldly
pointing out the obvious the winner of
the US Championship has a guaranteed
seat on our Olympic team in the past the
rating favorites have won the
competition so that hasn't is so it's
Kamsky wins and he was gonna get in by
reading anyway precisely but if a ray
Robson won a Lenderman one somebody
lower rated they could get on our US
squad and that's why the game one
between Lenderman and Ray is so vitally
important not only to the national
championship but to the aspirations of
our Olympiad our Olympic team shall we
just know that my mistakes are even
higher and we're going to be a bit back
with more from this critical round for
action here at the US Chess Championship
in st. Louis
and we're back at the u.s. Chess
Championship here we see the lovely
tournament room where we have photos of
Champions and contenders of us chess
championships past I think I see Robert
has some where they are on the wall he
is now actually hosting live commentary
I'm Lester is right next door and Lester
is keeping really busy with Yale and
with the sports quotient but you may be
needing a bit active trying maybe to get
back into it and I'm blessing us with
his commentary here exactly and I'm
hopeful that Robert or Ben who are doing
the live commentary at Lester's next
door will actually come by and give us
some insights as to what they've been
following it's really an exciting
weekend forecast because in addition to
the US Chess Championship we've got the
elementary nationals going on in Dallas
right now you mentioned that as we were
coming on air and some extraordinary
thing is going on there at Dallas well
there's a there's actually a sixth-grade
girl and she Emily Mew in and she is
leading the k-6 open sector so boys and
girls exactly so it's nice that you see
you live with a perfect 5-0 score that's
the incredible thing five wins perfect
Wow
so that's why we always refer to the US
Women's Championship and the u.s.
championship because there have been a
lot of championships where we have had a
couple of women contend a-absolutely and
they're certainly open to play in it
right now in the Elementary's juniors at
high school and high school you do see a
lot more girls at that levels and then
suddenly it's by by the time they go to
the University College and start a young
career a lot more the percentages are
incredibly high the terms of the numbers
of girls that's drop out a playing
competitive chess and that's one of the
reasons I think that we don't see
more women in the Open Championship here
just because the numbers change so
dramatically when you're in elementary
school I go to those elementary school
championships and it's almost 50/50 in
terms of boys and girls but by the time
they get to let's say the end of their
college the number of women competing
goes way down but you have more insights
on those numbers than I do that's true I
don't think point fifty-fifty but I do
think that it's getting better and
better closer to that and I like to see
the girls at the very top boards to
Emily and then Jennifer you last week a
couple weeks ago in the junior high
school that's six and a half out of
seven but unfortunately she drew her
first game so she never actually got to
play the person who got 7 wasn't that
crazy not be the winner or the co-winner
yeah playing for the champions are oh
wow but she's a cuz I was I was proud of
myself and being the highest rated
Jennifer so for me you're the best
Jennifer ever Jennifer a really common
name in the United States not so common
around the world and Russia and China
and a lot of the countries where they
they raise a great female chess champion
well really one of the things that I'm
really impressed with in women's chess
at the highest level at one time Georgia
the country of Georgia was dominant in
chess all Soviet Union Georgia really
really produced the best women and today
it's China India and literally the CIS
countries but the enormous jump that the
Chinese women have had in an a
professional chess for the women's game
has really been nothing short of
incredible it's awesome although I think
it's like it stagnated a bit now right
because they used to win every labhyate
and World Championship and L you see uh
well I guess yeah you see a little bit
more of changing hands right yes a
little bit so so I think they just
raised the bar yes without the question
which is great exactly when I keep to
see that happening and actually uh
Daniel Ranch
who's with chess calm said that he's at
the u.s. chess nationals watching our
coverage so shout out to everybody in
Dallas absolutely no shall we I just got
back to the game a bit between Lenderman
and Robson on our board one really not
much changes have happened both players
have gone into kind of deep things ray
as we noted throughout the rounds has
this propensity of getting himself into
time trouble misusing this clock
he hasn't been punished for his bad use
of time management that he has to be
careful because we know that Lenderman
is well very well prepared let's go
around the horn a little bit could see
some other games this is our game of
teamwork area of on board - got the kind
of positions that we had expected Jen I
do believe he played your move back here
when we got to this position oh yes we
were talking about this earlier
I'm very early in the broadcast we
talked about the the Schliemann being
played and now instead of that Queen d3
earlier if you want to back up a bit
yeah so I was expecting that in this
position we would see a queen bee three
rocks the idea that you would stop
castling because a Queen's e4 check
right but I think molnár maybe saw some
recent games and thought that blacks
chances for equality were too great so
he decided to go another out and simply
develop allow passing which I always
thought to be like I guess if you study
the theory it's easier but it's like if
you haven't really looked at it and you
just get this position in blitz it's
kind of unpleasant that black has that
open file yes yes exactly
that's why people you're often playing
the Queen d3 yeah right but in this
particular case Mac has been very very
quick to eliminate that bishop that was
eyeballing that pawn on f2 so that takes
a lot of the sting on at the open F file
if you will agreed yeah let's just see
what has happened so that's really
clever because I if you don't if you
don't watch out sometimes the Schliemann
can just
oh wait a second position symmetrical
said black isn't open a file in your
work right exactly I think we've just
seen Bishop age or the reason I'm
hesitating here a bit because as you
know I'm an old punk rubber I see it an
opportunity to grab a paw and I'm sure
going to take more than a secondary look
at it that's right I see what you're
trying to do as you know it I saw this
the whole series of captures takes the
bishop it takes the knight takes the
knight takes the knight then suddenly
this old double attack the Queen comes
out here with check going after the pawn
and c6 and we're I hesitated was the
move d5 and just what put this on the
board for a quick second you might think
oh that's a terrible move doesn't that
just blunder Pont well yes and no there
is a scure of the bishop against the
rook and that was where I was getting
tripped up in my thoughts trying to
figure out who who was favored by this
trade of oh you mean because we're gonna
get to bond doctor precisely precisely
that's alright kinda like thinking
though that our pollen c6 might be
tremendously weak there at the end
uh-huh so okay I'll just do I'll just
put this on the board so you're thinking
that this this this I've got this
wonderful nice four versus two majority
but what you're saying is this pawn may
be a bridge too far if we if we go after
it immediately the problem is the e5 one
hand right right so the the rover yes
yes okay which is kind of a nice
attacking and defensive move because it
hints it works e5 keeps pressure on a2
and Fendi five yeah and this is well
these are the sharp lines the type of
sharp lines that I find myself you know
while I'm at the board trying to
calculate to a finish that I'm
comfortable with if I like I can get to
a position where in my judgment the
position favors me I'll just go for it
but anyway that was a just a quick
cursory look and let me just see what
was played
because players don't like to just give
up their bishops talk talk talk and Mack
did make that retreating move that we've
just seen Bishop g5 can add drop back to
the h4 Square and T Marg area one I
believe he has played it I just want to
say that there's so many times instances
where the black king is vulnerable on
the g8 square that very often you see
this move King h8 just tucking the king
away and it's no longer exposed to a
check when it might be unpleasant that's
right so are you prefer King h8 to
Kincaid 7 yes and it's funny me because
in the old Soviet school there was a
Soviet dictum I want to say that when
you have a choice between moving your
king to either the square H 8 or H 7 on
what do you base your decision okay
you're ready for this you're gonna I'm
going to give you a chance to guess are
you most likely to get checked on
clothes on which color square is your
opponent's Queen oh wow and this was
actually talked to me by one of the
great trainers of the Soviet school of
chess
Edward gue Feld who was a trainer to the
Women's World Championship written in C
so in this position you would say I'm
gonna move my king I'm gonna move my
king to h8 or h7 what square what color
square is White's Queen on well it's all
on light square hence King h8 is a
automatic isn't it that's always fun
but it stayed with me for 25 years but
the important thing is
do move your king when it's an expose
there you go choose one of them we've
got a grandmaster Ashley with more on
another one of our exciting games here
in Ron for the US you have me - well
that's a weird rule I never heard it
before yes and I'm gonna try to get it
out of my head so I can actually think
about what to do in the position instead
of following some archaic rule but in
this position we're in the more modern
age where there's some modern practices
afoot and you can tell the influence of
the computer on this the computer
generation if you take a look at this
position again after eight h.d five
queen takes d5 we saw the move Knight to
b5 of course that night was under attack
threatening this fork
we saw the knight go to a six the side
of the board defending against a fork
that same night moving yet again to c3 a
queen dropping all the way back to the
d8 square and then the unusual move a
three I mean it just looks silly you see
this movie say what is the point of that
it's the stop a bishop he or a knight
here I don't get it
well it turns out it's Houdini's first
choice why because of the next move
Bishop to e7 is now met by the super
strange Queen to f3 we say keep your
Queen back in the opening uh uh Queen f3
threatening of all things if you castled
in this moment wondering what the Queen
is there for Bishop takes Knight oops
and all of a sudden you just lost a rook
bad idea so Queen f3 has a very concrete
threat to take this night on the a6
square forcing black to respond and now
black has to make a good move another
unusual move here the move Knight d5
would be Houdini's first choice safe and
sound
instead Ramirez maybe not having seen
this a3 move before played the move
Knight to c5 according to Houdini
White's already better needs to just
play the move Knight to c4 another
Knight move how many times will these
Knights move in the game and now
preparing after the natural castles to
play Bishop to f4 and look at that the
black
is suddenly caged somehow a rook is
heading to d1 and this is a very tricky
annoying position for black to play not
having seen it before
now Ramirez is kind of unlucky that he's
facing these youngsters who are coming
up with novelties we saw yesterday
Linderman played a very nice game
against him we should probably take a
look at that game at some point I'll
bring it up later in the broadcast
Linderman played a nice novelty a
strange move and poor Ramirez was blown
off the board from the get-go and now we
see the blue of 94 has landed on the
board now reducing this novelty with the
strange a3 and queen of three the
computer has changed everything and
we're seeing strange but original and
interesting chess all at the same time
here at these championships back to you
guys that's a perfect setup for a insult
but Tigran Petrosian labelled against my
generation he called my generation of
chess players children of the
informative in other words there was a
series of chess books that my generation
treated as a kind of a Bible and we
studied the novelties in the games of
that tool and today we have the children
of the computer cycle you know I love
that story yeah yeah Daniel who I have
actually had a training a training
session or two with I know that he
really enjoys using the computer as an
analytical tool and pourer alejandro
ramirez may have just fallen into one of
many of the novelties that daniel
prepares because he's a hard worker he
really does spend a good deal of his
time using the computer and using it as
a great analysis weapon maurice if you'd
like to follow up on the nice point that
you just brought up please do indeed yes
there is I made a mistake because I
looked at the
bored I realized the move order is
different even though Houdini does say
nicéphore is its first choice
Daniel plated second choice to move
before in this position so he in fact
played this move I seen his Knight on c4
and thought he had played that move
first but he played b4 chasing the night
off of this square and now take a look
at that night remember it was once on b8
and went to a6 he goes to c5 and now
it's back on
d7 does this make any sense and now the
move Knight to c4 has been played so
this is the position we're looking at
kind of surprising that narrow disc II
didn't play the move Knight to c4
immediately which was Houdini's first
choice maybe he thought that maybe
Ramirez had seen that position and would
think he'd go down that line so he would
have analyzed this one much more deeply
but still an original position on the
board you'd be hard-pressed to guess
what opening this came from it looks you
know kind of French ish but this
structure is just plain weird I mean
this over here just doesn't look like it
makes any sense whatsoever how this
occurred with the Queen out no bishops
out and I haven't not castles either
side after 12 moves so definitely
original chess a foot back to you guys
okay thank you for that clarification
and we're gonna take a little break and
as has become customary we are going to
treat you to another Bobby Fischer
puzzle for the break but remember that
you have a few tasks in the rank solve
this Bobby Fischer problem and call your
mom for Mother's Day
this one is a misfire reverse of Bobby
Fischer black move from the 1961 US
Chess Championship
welcome back to our coverage of the 2014
US Chess Championships we're in Round
four
how many of you guys found during the
break Queen 63 and called your mother
well a gold star for you exactly and we
are gonna have a grand master Maurice
actually explain why this Queen
sacrifice does the legendary Grandmaster
Arthur bit Squire in well Jen certainly
biz why I thought he had some
possibilities here after he played the
move rook to d1 a little cutesy moved
the nightís pin so therefore you can't
take because you'll lose your queen what
he didn't know is that Fischer didn't
mind losing his Queens second of Queen
was was simple for Fischer in fact the
game of the century dubbed by Hans
Camacho's the game of the century that
Fischer played against Donald Byrne was
one of those Queen sacrifices this one
was just a simple one give me that all
right and then after you take give me
the other guy and now the fork on the
Queen and the bishop means that on the
next move the bishop is going to go and
this Queen as mighty a piece as she is
stands no chance at all against all
these pieces this boy I tried to fight
back with the move be 6 but rook to c5
very solid ultra solid control of the
dark squares the move e5 was played and
Franck went the first pawn and after b7
the Queen was captured a new Queen
appeared on the board but the critical
passed pawn had now disappeared and it
was just all she wrote after takes takes
Queen takes d6 rook C takes on d5 Queen
to c7 and now 92 chasing down that last
straggler it tried to advance but it
didn't matter and after Queen to a7 the
move rook F back to d5 Queen a1 and
Knight Queen a1 and Knight to f4 and big
wire realized that soon black was going
to be able to bring the rook down and it
was gonna be a swarm of attack on his
King and the game was gonna be over soon
so he said no mas so a nice Queen
sacrificed by Fischer sure you guys out
there found that though right back to
you Jenny yes I did
of course I knew the game it was the
King on wrong color square I didn't
matter there I'm just gonna say to our
audience I am following very carefully
the game between our tournament leader
Alex Slenderman as Ray Robson has
sharpened up the game considerably by
sacrificing an exchange I'm very
exciting and in fact that game that I
referred to earlier in the broadcast
that Russian defence also feature an
exchange sack by Robson so a lot of
symmetry going on here mm-hmm the
Lenderman Robson Meadows will show us
how that exchange got sacked ok so just
going back a few moves
Ray had played what Maurice had
described as this novelty this move rook
eat rook on FA to e8 in the database
that move had not been seen Lenormand
played what looked like the normal move
rook on F wanted e1 getting behind his
passport and bang out came this exchange
sacrifice rook takes III lopping off the
bishop the rook wasn't recaptured and
then the move Knight on a6 to be for
trying to use some of these light
squares over here on a d3 and c2
Lenderman blocked the diagonal of that
bishop remember earlier we were having
this discussion of whether or not black
should try to trade the light square
bishop with Bishop h3 Rey has kept the
bishop but now with this move 94 this
pawn on c5 is under attack
and I think I'm not sure exactly what
Ray has in mind but I think what he has
in mind is to capture this Knight and to
try to play on the dark squares based
upon this move rook e8 we'll see whether
in that and that line of play is indeed
what ray is intending
but a very sharp position on our top
board at the battle really heating up in
this game kind of has to right I mean
sure and bishops under attack so let's
drop the bishop to a light square I
heard this one I never quite thought of
it before a bishop is a prisoner to only
32 squares on the chess board prisoner
to 32 squares I thought that was an
interesting way of putting it I guess
you could look at a glass half-full or
grass half-empty it's also free to
explore 30 there
exactly exactly we gotta hear it so what
about but you make six for instance
right is that kind of hitting on that
part right now that's would White be
able to just advance with Evora right
that would be the question to advance
with the movie for I think what Ray
wants to do actually is somehow exploit
this diagonal either with a move such as
Queen a4 okay trying to set up for the
possibility of at raise and it captures
or something which looks kind of strange
putting your knight way over here on a
four trying to exploit the fact that
this Knight may get itself a little bit
stuck just to continue the line for a
quick second rook comes to D to D file
so I can do the cheapo rookie 3:54
exactly the new bishop h3 h6 has more
possibility but I was thinking that this
is a very deep exchange sacrifice indeed
if if Ray had intended to play in such a
fashion of simply advancing his pawns on
the Queen side that's right we would
love to play these c4 lines but our
night isn't take so you're saying be 5mn
85023 kind of a quiet moves and you get
a crazy position White has advanced his
passer past deep on with a move d6 then
comes a 5
who is getting in there quickest is this
threat of C 5 C 4 worth a whole exchange
hard to tell at this moment will follow
this this match closely because it's
going to be critical right not only for
these moves that both of these player is
just really bringing it very young
players Robson was with us earlier in
the tournament he said that he likes to
play aggressive chess so we don't have
to worry about him making quick draws or
playing the dryest long as he loves this
you just try it in real life sometimes
exactly so it's funny how with some
people they show their they've had they
show their actual personality on the
board and some people it's like they
kind of show what you're not saying
exactly exactly yeah so we've mentioned
Mother's Day a few times today and today
were graced to have a mother from the US
Championship not the one playing the
Women's Championship but actually a
mother of a great talent in the US
Championship Daniel Meredith ski we've
mentioned narrative skis awesome
accomplishments before that he was
accepted to Stanford and he also has a
Sanford scholarship and he's written two
books and he's Grandmaster and he's in
the u.s. championship no doubt that
there were some supportive parents
behind that absolutely Molina has been
traveled with her son all over the world
and she's here to tell us what's it like
having a prodigy in the family with
fantastic hair I might mention okay
thanks Jen well we have with us Lina
narrowed its key the mother of Daniel
narrowed its key in the tournament happy
Mother's Day
first of all thank you so when did you
know you had your hands full with a boy
genius how old was he and what were the
signs at first it wasn't a sign of a
genius at first it was just an interest
in chess at about six and a half of
seven but then it progressed pretty fast
and when did you see it when did you
know like you had time winning local
tournaments and
and state tournaments and the Nationals
and in all the Scholastic's that he went
to and then it progressed pretty fast
and then in about a year we started to
realize that oh we need a coach indeed
I'm sure you're not a Grand Master
player yourself I've never played a game
in my life that must be odd all the
attention he's gotten and seeing him
write books I mean that's the frame
incredible he started writing the first
book when he was 12 and and the first
question we've we heard about it was he
said well how do you publish a book that
was the question so we thought that okay
we will have to self publish some
something he writes he writes a lot
besides just so we knew he likes to
write but then we never expected it to
be a book at the age of 14 to be
published by the most prestigious chess
publishing house in the Netherlands
that's pretty new HS that's pretty
incredible indeed and you've gone to a
lot of chess tournaments what's a
typical day like for you here at the
championships here it's just almost the
same as in the normal tournament except
that he wears instead of shorts and
t-shirt he's he has two who here have
respectable clothes so so I do have to
iron the shirt and I have to serve him
breakfast and it's every day is the same
as the next one he likes it that way so
it's like a routine and then I have to
gently tell him that it would be nice to
run a couple of miles down in the gym
and he he does listen so far but it's
only the fourth game I fourth round so I
don't know what's gonna happen it's 11
round tournament and it's very tough you
might lose a game or two and start
saying mom you know you need to get out
of my hair okay I gotta do my yeah well
like we'll see but what I I'm being
there for him and then I have to pull
him out once he loses like he did
yesterday and you have to somehow help
him out for the next day it's a mother
coach as well no I mean mother I do bag
maybe
how is this tournament different from
other tournaments you've been to I mean
you've been to lots of chess tournaments
how is this one especially here in st.
Louis Louis is unbelievable this this is
obviously not the first time he's
playing here and I've I've been to every
one of them with him and I just I will
use this opportunity to thank the club
and especially Rex and Jeanne and and
everyone on the staff everyone at the
club the players are treated the way
that no other tournament at least we've
never been to a super tournament I guess
that's how it is over there because it's
just amazing how are they're treated
with I mean the hotel they the
environment in the Chess Club the
conditions are unbelievable I think
these these young men or older men they
deserve to be treated like that because
they work very very hard and they
perform so well so I think that this
tournament being in st. Louis just
there's no comparison indeed and I echo
that sentiment and I just the men
getting treated well of course but the
women and mothers and everyone as well
everyone gets even the commentators I
might ask so we know that you're a music
teacher a piano teacher actually and you
do support other students in musical
competitions how is that similar to
chess competent ell my parents of my
students I do teach in the San Francisco
Conservatory of Music and I teach
children professionally and they I raise
them from when they are very young until
they go to college and they do
participate in competitions and recitals
obviously and all kinds of performances
and I always tell those mothers that are
very worried and very nervous and wet
hands and cold feet and and all that
nervousness I always tell them well you
need to go to a chess tournament because
that performance times 11 like in this
one everyday you'll get used to it and
you'll stop being nervous all
to be honest I I'm still very very very
under pressure every time he plays and
especially this is such an important
tournament and to be it's a huge huge
honor for him to be in such a tournament
among these players well and there's no
piano trying to check beat you as well
so even more difficult well thanks so
much Lina nard it's key for joining us
we wish you the best in your son the
best in the rest of the competition
thank you for giving me any opportunity
back to you Jen and yes a wonderful
family by the way it was a few years ago
I visited them in their home I did a
little training with Daniel for about a
week and father Vladimir and mother Lina
very very supportive at Daniel about it
was last I last year at the US Open I
swear Daniel grew 1/2 a foot I looked at
my shoes because I thought I was
standing in a hole because he had grown
so much he's really really developed
admirably and I mean fingers crossed for
his success in his second championship
by the way this is not his debut in the
US Championships a lot of yeah yeah and
it was a it was the nickname that his
mother used and it was a nick in its his
handle on the internet chess club as
well so I it it's a and then it's an
endearing name I like it a lot my
brother's name is Daniel too so it helps
me to different differentiate between
between them well we have a couple of
other interesting games going on you
want to take a look at molar graph one
other thing I that interest me in the
interview is that Lina is so interested
in music and of course wrecks in GTA and
in particular or so involved in music
initiatives so it does seem that there's
this relationship between chess and
music that's a lot of people are
interested in both mm-hmm
or that in favor is a similar type of
mine I think that chess and music have
so much in common
and we do see in the world of chess this
combination of music oftentimes
synchronized it somehow I think of for
example vasily smyslov or for example
lyusia Cordish from hungary to really
legendary players both are actually
great singers as well sorry but you had
mentioned that the game to some exciting
things are going always had our eye on
because Ashley man right right and I
think we last looked at it around here
about pawn grabbing exactly and gaudy F
had played the move Queen e8 to just
prevent those pawn grabbing ideas that
we had looked at a moment ago this
knight on f3 is not doing anything super
special so Mac played the move Knight d2
trying to figure out a better circuit
for the night for example it might seem
oops
my arrows have been terrible a whole
competition of trying to get to a more
favorable square like the d5 or maybe
even the FI thought post so he played
the move 92
similarly timur said the knight on f6 is
not doing anything how about if i
skedaddle over here the f4 is an
excellent outpost for a black knight as
we went very well know this should drop
back to g3 suggesting that white is
ready to trade bishop came out to e6
bishop back to c4 queen at 7 and again i
actually liked black's pawn structure
very much in these positions and i think
black has not only equalized but given
the choice of which side i might prefer
i probably go for tea
Moore's position actually interesting
yeah I think that's one of the issues
that's a Schliemann that actually if
white does improve something black
sometimes gets a really nice position
I'm on way to do so some kind of
tactical thing before you get to
consolidate your King position and
that's why I'll go back to move four or
five whatever it is this move d2 d3
really doesn't put pressure on the black
player and that's why you've got to go
into those sharper lines but to go into
those sharper lines you've got to have
done the preparation and have the
confidence that you've worked harder
than your opponent or if you are gonna
play d3 I think that Queen d3 move
production casting is is pretty helpful
yeah Magnus Carlsen has played that
before so a lot of very strong players
have and this opening preparation not
quite working but certainly far from
over
Oh without question is still in but all
the play for all results are possible of
course and so I I'm sorry I did want to
go back to that game on our feature
table between Ray Robson and our
tournament leader Alec Slenderman ray
has come up mixed it up with an exchange
sacrifice we left it about these parts
takes 94 94 and Ray said you know I am
I'm generally genuinely worried about
this pawn on e4 let me capture it which
he did Knight takes Knight takes Queen
e7 and so ray is saying I'm satisfied
that I've got this great Bishop on g7
even though I know man I'm an exchange
down ray is eyeballing this pawn on e3
if he can capture that pawn as well then
he'll have a pawn and Bishop for the
exchange
very sharp position I'm still not sure
how I would assess this one super messy
just like their last group oh yeah you
like to see the girl
you're gonna have a pitch battle for
sure
so we're missing the women's in today
because they usually plays such exciting
jazz but they have a free day today and
so my master Maurice Ashley is going to
go over that thriller from yesterday so
that is between the young soir on who
has two out of three in the Women's
Championship and she played against
Camilla behind Sky t indeed Jen we had a
battle of the youngest and the oldest in
that competition yesterday young ash
rethus were on against Camilla Greg and
Skye T and surprisingly the youngster
pulled it out in her very first
championship having already won a game
and then losing now
in a critical matchup with by getting
Skye T she got this position offering a
trade of Queens on the board and her
opponent play the move Queen to d5
threatening a discovered check and what
happened here is she ignored it she
played 87 and now we saw the the pawn go
forward with a check King up and that
pawn now trying to become a queen and we
got the unusual situation of seeing for
Queens count them four of them on the
chessboard with white to move you would
have thought that this would be a
devastating easy win for white but it
turns out that there is no mate no
series of checks actually does anything
at all and here after this move in time
pressure both sides a 3-1 played Queen B
3 check and it was critical right at
this moment with seconds on her clock
for begging sky 10 to play the move
Queen to c3 in fact she missed this move
this move would have saved her and she
thought that maybe this check would have
been too dangerous but this King move
with check counter check actually to the
King would have been just fine for black
if not winning so in this position here
after Queen to b3 she missed that move
play King to d4 Queen takes Queen check
and after Queen takes on e4 actually I
should point out that she could not play
sorry about that that she could not play
King takes because of this skewer so
instead she played Queen takes
for and then after Queen takes before
check the Queen's are gonna be traded
the pawns too far separated mated and
absolutely easy win for white Camilla
Bergen sky set was devastated after the
game and she sat at the board trying to
figure out where and I gone wrong where
did I going wrong you see her here
sitting and after this check saying what
is it what did I miss
I'm sure by now she knows exactly what
she missed but she lost a full point in
that battle to the youngster who was all
smiles yesterday in the interview she
couldn't even speak afterwards and was
happy to get a rest day and enjoy with
her mom who had just arrived what a gift
for Mother's Day to win a big game here
at the US Women's Championship back to
you Jenna yes yeah pretty awesome to see
that it was but it's the mark of a
champion that even after losing such a
disappointing game she's more focused on
the chess than the disappointment you
know she's like what did I do wrong not
I'm so upset that I lost to this lowest
rated player in the field absolutely I
mean losses are a power to the game and
I recall when I was in high school I was
doing a lot of diving and the number of
belly flops and yeah I I had my wipeouts
but the reality is is after a wipeout
and you and the sting that you
experience from spanking the pool you
you get up on the diving board for the
next dive and you just learn from each
experience and that's the mark of a
champion as well taking your losses and
trying to learn from them in them the
end of the game you saw Camila doing her
best to decipher what did she go do
wrong and where did she miss her
opportunity to cool things about that
came usually when there are four award
which doesn't happen that often no
usually the role is the first person who
checks wins exactly okay so this is kind
of a funny exact counter example of that
precisely in my experience I played
about 4,000 tournament games
countless Blitzen why have you games but
in my tournament experience I only
recall one time where there were four
Queens on the board so it is so rare
that's to be it's like a royal flush it
just really rarely rarely happens it's
not supposed to be the one making them
yes and yeah actually um we we talked
earlier about how the world chess Hall
of Fame has these two great new openings
yeah I'm one which is involving music
and chess and the artist Glen Cano said
the one of the things he is intrigued by
chests so much and he's really into
chess
yeah it's like a big chess library he
studies duchamp games and he brought up
this Heidegger quote that said the
possible out racks the agile so that
means that in chess it's like there's so
many cool variations but you rarely get
to see the coolest variations on the
board so I feel like that's the kind of
thing with four Queens that's the kind
of thing you're gonna see when you're
variations a lot but to actually have it
on the board right so rare Wow cool I
have just brought up a game between var
Akopian and Josh frito not that I'm
trying to give my pack myself a pat on
the back but the remarkable thing is
that we were both discussing that crafty
little move of by var just back in this
moment white just had played this move
b2 b3 just advancing as beef on and then
sometimes when you do that and then you
you take another step at the pond before
there's a very hard moves to see he's
trying to take advantage of the fact
that for black to win back the pawn he
had sacrificed earlier it will at least
allow white this protected past pawn on
d5
now when we had left it we were kind of
developed debating the merits or the
strengths and weaknesses I should say of
this Knight on b4 on the one hand
it's protected it's a reasonable outpost
on the other hand it's a possibility
that this night may remain out of the
game while retreats where exactly and
the game actually did continue as
follows and we've got a position where
from a material point of view it's very
balanced but it's really it's still an
open question of whether this night will
play a role in the future and in the
meanwhile if you ever get into very
simplified ending this pawn on b5 could
easily carry the day for white so still
a very double-edged battle I would say
all three results once again impossible
it sounds like you like white a little
bit
I hope v6 doesn't make an impression on
you as a blockade er no III I have a
slight preference for white here nothing
special and we have Maurice with
something for us and our key matchup of
the day between tournament leader
Alexander Linderman and Ray raphson
indeed this looks like a barnburner
happening here now we saw in this
position that black play the rook
exchange sacrifice rook takes III F
takes on e3 and then the move Knight to
b4 black pieces starting to encroach on
White's position white play Knight to e4
centralizing his knight and this piece
looking so strong the computer thought
best to just kill it now just take it
now and play the position after that
with a Knight to a4 in line that you
looked at yes but instead in this
position Robson played this move Houdini
says what are you doing that's garbage
we don't like that at all Knight takes
e5 Queen to e7 Bishop takes on d5
removing a knight and Queen takes and
now Bishop takes on f7 with check now
white is up an exchange and a pawn in
this position and now King to h8 and
this is the position that Lenderman is
looking at Houdini is giving white a
huge edge saying whites just winning
after rook a to see